Dado que "g" de "x" es igual a "8x" más 2,
encuentra "g" de 0,
"g" de -5
y "g" de "2x" más 3.
Muy bien,
esto de acá es lo único
que podría aparecer un poco raro,
pero básicamente,
nos están definiendo una función,
y una función,
consiste en que a un cierto valor "x",
lo metemos en la función,
que podemos pensarlo como una caja
aquí está, la función "g"
y de ahí obtenemos un valor a cambio,
en este caso resulta que
el valor que obtenemos, es el "8x" más 2,
o sea, multiplicamos el número por 8
y le sumamos 2.
Muy bien, entonces si aquí metiéramos el 1,
digamos,
¿qué tendríamos que hacer?
tendríamos que meter el 1 a la definición de "g",
en todos los lugares donde aparece "x"
lo cambiamos por 1,
así que nos quedaría,
8 por 1 que es 8 más 2...
más 2... 8 más 2 es 10,
entonces aquí saldría un 10, vale, aquí saldría un 10.
Ok, con eso dicho, vamos a encontrar "g" de 0,
"g" de -5  y "g" de "2x" más 3.
Déjame empezar con "g" de 0.
Lo voy a poner con colores para que sea un poco más claro...
entonces queremos determinar "g"...
"g" de 0, vale,
entonces éste es el que voy a hacer ahorita.
¿Cómo le hacemos para determinar "g" de 0?
Pues en todos los lugares
donde aparezca "x" en la definición de "g"
tenemos que cambiar esa "x" por un 0,
entonces nos quedaría 8 multiplicado por 0...
por 0...
que voy a poner en color rojo mejor...
y a eso tenemos que sumarle 2,
más 2, vale.
Aquí ya podemos hacer las operaciones,
8 por 0 es 0,
cualquier cosa por 0 es 0,
esto se hace 0,
si a 0 le sumamos 2 nos queda 2,
vale,
entonces déjame escribir por aquí al lado, que "g" de 0,
"g" de 0 es igual a 2.
Vamos con "g" de -5,
"g" de -5
déjame hacerlo con este color rosa, va,
entonces nos piden determinar "g" de -5,
muy bien.
Misma idea, cada vez que tengamos una "x",
hay que cambiarla por un -5,
y entonces nos quedaría 8
multiplicado por...
y aquí tendríamos que poner el -5,
por -5
y a eso tenemos que sumarle 2...
más 2...
¿Cuánto nos queda?
8 por -5 es -40,
a esto tenemos que sumar 2,
-40 más 2 es igual a -38.
Y por lo tanto "g" de -5...
"g"de -5 es igual a -38,
muy bien,
entonces esto fue el segundo problema.
Vamos al tercero,
que se ve un poquito más interesante.
Mira, nos piden determinar
"g" de "2x" más 3,
ahora no tenemos un número
sino que tenemos toda una expresión.
¿Cómo le hacemos para esto?
pues mismísima idea,
es más, déjame poner
un ejemplo un poco más extremo.
¿Qué pasa si nos piden determinar "g",
"g" de círculo naranja?
Esto va a ser un poco raro,
pero espero que veas la idea.
Si nos piden determinar,
"g" de círculo naranja,
básicamente tenemos que hacer lo mismo,
cada vez que aparezca una "x",
la tenemos que cambiar por un círculo naranja,
entonces sería 8...
8 multiplicado por un círculo naranja,
esto está como raro, verdad,
pero bueno es la idea,
y a eso tenemos que sumarle 2.
Si tuviéramos una estrella,
sería 8 por estrella más 2.
como aquí tenemos un "2x" más 3,
que déjame ponerlo con este color verde claro...
como tenemos un "2x" más 3,
tenemos que cambiar todas las "x" por "2x" más 3,
entonces "g"
"g" de "2x" más 3
"2x" más 3,
Es igual...
es igual a
8 multiplicado por lo que valga "x"
y a eso tenemos que sumarle 2,
déjame hacer un poco más de espacio.
Tenemos que sumarle 2,
entonces,
¿qué va aquí adentro?
pues va el valor de "x",
pero ahora tenemos la expresión "2x" más 3,
entrando a la función,
entonces tenemos que poner aquí "2x" más 3,
sería 8 por "2x" más 3.
Y ¿cuánto nos quedaría?
Pues a ver 8 por "2x" es "16x"...
"16x"
3 por 8 es 24,
y también tenemos que sumar este 2
más... lo voy a poner así,
más 2
y entonces,
¿qué nos quedaría?
nos quedaría "16x"
más 26
"16x" más 26,
déjame reescribirlo aquí,
"g" de "2x" más 3,
"2x" más 3, es igual a
"16x" más 26.
Entonces este último inciso
pudo resultar un poco complejo o confuso,
pero la idea es muy sencilla,
simplemente cualquier cosa que tengamos aquí,
aquí es "2x" más 3,
tenemos que sustituirla por "x"
y eso es un poco raro,
cambiar una expresión que tiene "x" por...
por esta "x" verdad,
como que parece algo extraño,
pero es básicamente esa idea,
si aquí tendría...
si aquí tuviéramos un triángulo,
sería 8 por triángulo más 2,
si tuviéramos una luna,
sería 8 por luna más 2,
y eso es exactamente lo que hicimos,
simplemente sustituimos lo que está adentro del paréntesis,
en donde estén todas las "x".